In book four of Paradise lost.
Milton had sketched the origins of human freedom.
And,
and you remember this Eve's first memory her,
her,
her reflection on her reflection in the pool had established the importance of,
of freedom and also the importance of,
of,
of independence for,
for not only her relation with Adam,
but essentially all of human relations.
So Milton's concerned in book four was to establish something like the viability
of a freedom that was able in some way to coexist with what we discussed was a
hierarchical set of,
of power relations.
And this coexistence of freedom on the one hand and,
and social hierarchy on the other is something that this poem,
uh,
continues to assert.
Um,
and I,
I would also add that it's something that this poem continues to worry about.
It's a,
it's an extraordinarily problematic but crucial element of,
of paradise lost.
Now,
let,
uh,
I'll just,
I want to review a couple of moments and in book four,
um,
think back to what eve had told Adam after,
after she had been compelled by him and also by the warning voice after she had
been compelled to channel all of her erotic energies away from the beautiful,
sympathetic,
responsive,
a watery image toward Adam.
And Eve had said,
thy gentle hand seized mine.
I yielded,
they gentle hand seized mine.
I yielded.
And theirs is a continual dance of,
of seizing and yielding.
You have his assertion of power and her gracious resignation.
And,
and,
and through,
although it's a gentle,
uh,
use of power on the one hand,
and it's a,
an independent and consensual resignation on the other.
And,
and through this dance,
Milton,
I think was trying to establish a model of human interaction really distinct
from,
from simple coercion are completely distinct from simple coercion.
It's distinct from the simple exercise of brute force that I think we often
associate with life in a hierarchically organized,
deciding
and human interaction in this poem is founded on a principle of,
of consent.
In the miltonic Commonwealth of Eden and we can think of it as a commonwealth.
Uh,
no one can be forced to act.
Um,
Eve has to choose to act.
She,
she has to consent to act.
She yields,
which is for Milton,
not actually a resignation.
It's a positive,
deliberative,
deliberate action.
And she has the,
she has the right of consent because she,
she,
she possesses for Milton and,
and inalienable capacity for free will and free choice.
So this account of,
of,
of Eve's first exercise of free will,
the one that I've just given you,
her yielding to Adam when he seizes her hand,
that's at least I think the official one that the poem urges us to accept a
according to the poems,
w what I'm thinking of the,
as the poems official philosophy because it seems to be a guaranteed or in some
way sub tended by the,
by the,
by the narrator and authoritative forces in the poem.
According to this philosophy,
eve yields to Adam freely and willingly because she comes to recognize his
superior is superior nature.
And the poem presses on us,
uh,
a philosophy whereby Eve's freedom is entirely compatible with the fact of,
or what we're asked to take as the fact of her inferiority to Adam.
And Satan himself explains perfectly,
uh,
th this philosophy and I think he gives us,
ironically,
it's Satan who gives us the best formulation of this coexistence of freedom and
hierarchy.
Um,
in,
in the,
in the poem that freedom and hierarchy are absolutely compatible.
Um,
Satan will tell,
uh,
ab deal and book five,
four orders and degrees jar,
not with liberty,
but well consist.
We can in reason or in right assume monarchy or who can in reason or in right as
soon monarchy over such as live by,
right,
his equals if in power and splendor,
less in freedom equal,
but Milton's poetry,
uh,
well think how it is.
First of all,
that it's Satan who's giving us something like the only,
uh,
carefully articulated authoritative position on this,
to say the least.
This controversial matter,
um,
say Milton's poetry is invariably more sophisticated than what we can think of
as the official dogma or the authoritative line of the poem.
Perhaps that that fact is revealed or exposed to us by the fact that it's Satan
who's giving us,
in this instance,
the authoritative line.
It's important to keep,
uh,
this distinction in mind because this poem simply cannot be reduced.
Sometimes it tries to be reduced,
but it cannot be reduced to those ringing declarations of what sound like the
official positions of the poem.
So think how complicated it is with Eve eve account of that beautiful pool side,
reverie was so filled with,
with pathos and,
and longing,
uh,
that it's impossible.
I think not to feel at least a little bit of disappointment when she consents
finally to her union with Adam.
It's,
it's almost,
I don't know,
there's kind of a sense in which she's sold out as a,
of course we're happy that she has a mate who's another person and not merely
merely a smooth watery image.
Nonetheless,
there's a sense of disappointment that attends that choice that she makes.
And initially for Eve,
I'm at least convinced there seemed to be nothing like freedom at all.
She remembers having gazed at that pleasing image in the reflective pool.
And she recalls being pulled away from that smiling and sympathetic image by
that mysterious voice that had guided her to Adam.
And,
and,
and I think this is one of the most moving lines in the entire poem.
Um,
when eve recalls the feeling of helplessness that she experienced when she heard
that voice.
And this is,
this is,
this is how she explains it later to Adam,
what could I do but follow straight invisibly,
thus led,
what could I do and not a bad question.
What could she do?
Uh,
the,
the subordination of woman to man in,
in Heterosexual Union and Paradise lost seemed entirely couples compulsory at
that moment.
And Eve,
it seemed on some level had to be coerced to unite herself with this less
pleasing Adam and Milton for,
for a moment at least,
Milton seem to be on the brink of a,
of something like a powerful critique of the so called naturalness of,
of normative,
uh,
of normative sexual behavior.
Because there's at least some suggestion here that Eve's attraction to to Adam
was not freely chosen at all.
It was chosen for her,
it was assigned to her,
and all of this is a way of saying that Milton is doing something
extraordinarily complicated in,
in paradise lost.
He's juxtaposing and he does this consistently.
He juxtaposes the rhetoric of rational consent on the one hand with the
competing rhetoric of,
of coercion,
and maybe that word's a little strong,
but a con competing rhetoric of something like a gentle compulsion,
if that oxymoron makes any sense.
There's a way in which the this entire scene,
which is intended to assert the politics of rational consent provides it the
very same moment.
Something like a critique of the politics of rational consent.
We know that that Eve's freely willed act of yielding,
followed,
followed in time.
Adam's exertion of force,
and so however gentle Adam is digestible hand seized mind,
he's still seized.
He still sees deve and Milton's I think remarkably honest.
So this is why I'm always pushing you to a agree with me and compelling you to
agree with me.
The,
that Milton deserves a little bit of credit here.
Um,
and it's,
it's amazingly honest.
His account of Eve's first exercise of her free will and I think we can think of
this as her,
this is her first free act.
And of course it is a,
an unduly circumscribed act of freedom and,
and ultimate's poetry and a lot of ways is constantly questioning the legitimacy
of a doctrine of freewill in a world that has been arranged and uh,
conjugated like the one that,
that,
that Eden has banned.
It's along a principle of hierarchy.
So book for had,
had explored in extraordinary detail the complexities of hierarchy and freedom
with respect to the relation between the sexes.
And book five is also interested in the relation,
this,
uh,
this uneasy but important relation between hierarchy,
hierarchy and freedom.
It's almost as if book for hadn't sufficiently put to rest the,
the,
the logical problem that on some level is constantly eating away at the center
of the poem.
And so and so book.
And so book five takes up this problem once again,
but it takes it up as we of course should have been led to expect.
It takes it up from an entirely different perspective.
So as I just said in book for the hierarchical principle of superiority and of
excellence,
um,
was the superiority of man to woman.
In book five,
the central hierarchical axis is a little different or a lot different in an
evolves the superiority of angels over over human beings and this new
hierarchical opposition if it's performing a lot of work.
But one of the things that is certainly doing is forcing us to rethink the
hierarchical opposition that Milton had established in book four.
And that's because hierarchy is no longer gendered.
In,
in book,
in book five,
Milton's not concerned here,
uh,
with sex,
he's concerned rather with decree degrees of materiality among all of God's
creatures,
angels are less material,
less core,
poorly burdened creatures than Adam and Eve.
And therefore within this system,
therefore they're superior.
And in this larger vision of a kind of cosmic principle of hierarchy in which
lighter,
more ethereal things are superior to heavier,
denser grocer material things.
We can see a way in which the gender distinction simply drops out of the
equation because Milton gives us no reason to think that Adam and eve or
anything but equal in terms of the degrees of their corporate reality.
Uh,
sexual inequality simply seems insignificant here from this New Perspective in
book five.
So Raphael descends into Eden.
They Archangel Rafiel in book five in order to warn Adam and eve not to eat the
forbidden fruit.
And in doing so,
he provides an elaborate account of one of the most,
and I've already discussed this,
but I have to discuss it again because if for me it's so outrageous and so
daring and such an absolutely loving,
lovable,
a religious hair heterodoxy maybe it's even a heresy that the,
the,
the heterodoxy of modernism.
And,
and I'll remind you briefly of what Mona Ism is.
It's the philosophy whereby there can be no such thing as a firm and absolute
distinction between body and spirit.
The world can't be divided into,
into soul and matter as it could be divided with absolute clarity for Milton's
contemporary Descartes,
the entire Cosmos for Milton is made of one huge blob of matter.
And this matter is nothing other ultimately than the body of God.
And this is what this is what Raefiel explains to Adam at line 469 of book five.
So this is page 313 in the Hughes edition.
So this is wrath yield to Adam Oh Adam,
one almighty is that's God from whom all things proceed and up to him return if
not deprived from good,
created all such to perfection.
One first matter all in dude with various forms,
various degrees of substance and in things that live of life.
One first matter,
all,
all things derive from the one first matter,
which is of course God.
And this is the x Dayo,
uh,
theory of creation,
cray audio x Dayo as opposed to the orthodox theory of creation,
which is cray audio exnayed.
Hello.
The notion that God created the universe out of nothing.
Milton has god creating the universe out of God himself from the body of God.
And in this x day Oh creation scenario,
that there is no qualitative difference,
uh,
between the substance comprising men in the substance comprising angels.
Uh,
the difference is simply one of degree.
This has been a brilliantly argued by the critic William Kerrigan.
It's a difference of degree rather than a difference of kind of angels are
simply lighter.
Uh,
the corporeal substance that makes up their bodies is more attenuated.
It's more rarefied than that in human beings.
And,
and we are,
we are all a more condensed.
We're grocer creatures to use Milton's,
uh,
one of Milton's favorite words here.
Um,
our gross or bodies are more compacted.
Uh,
there are,
uh,
a denser,
a consistency then the light and airy bodies of heavenly angels.
And so,
except for this differentiation of degree by subsidy by a of the degree of
substantiality human beings and angels are qualitatively identical,
uh,
that were made of the same stuff.
It's just how closely pack this stuff is.
And Milton even treats us to a scene of Adam and eve because it's thinkable in
such a mechanistic universe,
although it's wild of Adam and eve actually eating with the Archangel Raefiel.
And,
and,
and this is a,
I think this must've blown Milton's contemporaries away because from any
orthodox perspective,
this asked this attribution of,
uh,
what Milton would call a gross activity,
like eating to one of one of God's heavenly minions,
one of the angels.
Um,
what would have to be seen if it's not blasphemous,
it's,
it's certainly in decorous,
but this is,
this is of course a poem that's centered around an illicit act of,
of eating.
And so Milton,
we'll,
we'll turn the entire activity eating into the premise of an entire philosophy
of their relation of human creatures to their God.
So in that all of God creek,
all of God's creatures need to eat angels and men can't seem,
can be seen to be equals.
And this is essentially Raphael's logic.
Look at line 411 of book five around fuel tells Adam,
this is page three 12 that the angels are a lot like human beings.
They hear,
see,
smell,
touch,
taste,
tasting,
concoct,
digest,
assimilate.
And we're soon,
uh,
we're,
we're starting to learn that angels also have sex because as we know,
Sarah spirits can either sex as soon or both,
but,
but we're,
we're about to find out here something.
I think it's a little more shocking even than that,
than the fact of angelic eroticism.
Angels have digestive tracts in Milton's heaven and like human beings,
they have within their bodies some kind of mechanism for the elimination of,
of ingested substances.
Um,
the elimination of substances that cannot be assimilated into the body.
So Milton's angels actually excrete this is,
uh,
this is,
this is the remarkable,
a remarkable feat of literary daring to be sure,
but it's also a,
a magnificent feat of the human imagination on Hilton's part.
And so this is what the narrator is,
seems to be referring to when he discusses Raphael's hunger.
This is line for 37
what redounds transpires through spirits with ease.
It's so easy to miss what rubdowns transpires through series spirits with ease.
What stays,
uh,
what,
what can't be assimilated into the body,
um,
gets,
uh,
gets expelled easily.
Uh,
Milton is so eager here.
Now we have to ask ourselves,
why is Milton doing this?
He's so eager.
I'm convinced to demonstrate the,
the essential metaphysical equivalents of human beings and angels that he is
quite prepared to ask us to imagine the unimaginable angels are exceedingly
regular.
Milton is telling us what redounds that that food which remains in excess in the
angel's body transpires through spirits with these.
And of course,
as we know,
Milton was acutely interested in his own,
in his own gastrointestinal tract,
having blamed his blindness on a digestive problem.
But there's a lot more here than merely a personal,
a personal interest.
Eating is so central to this poem,
but it's actually a,
something like a digestive process of assimilation and excretion that would have
enabled the unfollow and Adam and eve to become angels eventually themselves.
Uh,
turn to line four 93.
This is page three,
13.
It was to
be Adam and Eve's good fortune,
okay
to watch their own gross.
Corporeal body's slowly,
gradually shed.
They're dense matter as they assume the ery lightness of angels.
And,
and,
and how will they attain this extraordinary achievement,
this wafting up to heaven.
They'll do it by eating.
Look at line four 93.
Oh Ralph was explaining that as things are now angels are,
you know,
in a pinch,
angels are capable of a nutritional kind of condescension.
They can eat the same food that human beings eat when,
when they have,
when they don't have a choice.
And,
and right now,
Adam and eve probably couldn't survive on angelic nectar if that's all they had
to live on probably.
But Raefiel adds time may come when angels may put time,
may come when men with angels may participate and find no inconvenient diet nor
to light fair and from these corporal nutriments,
perhaps your body's May it last turn all to spirit,
improved by tract of time and wind.
Uh,
send the theory,
oh as we or May at choice here or in heavenly paradises dwell.
And this is obviously the kicker,
if you be found obedient,
okay.
Milton is going out of his way to provide Adam and eve with a motive for
remaining obedient by a simple process of eating a virtuous eating,
virtuous digestion,
and the sublime and the cons,
uh,
consequent activity of the virtuous,
a blinding.
That's Milton's term of gross matter into spirit.
Adam and Eve will eventually,
gradually begin to ascend to the wind,
the state of Angel Hood.
They will metabolize themselves into angels.
It's one of the most extreme visions and one of the most beautiful fishes.
However,
however cockamamie beautiful visions of human progress ever depicted.
I think so,
Ralph Fields account of the superior,
the superiority of spiritual matter over gross matter is without question,
another one of the poems,
hierarchical,
hierarchical visions,
but the,
the,
the amazing process of the,
what we can think of as the angel.
What would have been the angel lization of men and women doesn't.
Okay.
Does something really quite alarming,
I think to the principle of hierarchy as it's been presented so far.
The metaphysical hierarchy of the degree of material density,
which is the concern of book five isn't fixed.
It's not static in,
in Milton's universe.
And Raphael is,
this is,
uh,
this is a mobile society that Raefiel is imagining the hierarchy.
Heroes is flexible.
It's much more flexible than the gendered hierarchy was among human beings in,
in four.
And if an Adam and eve managed not to fall,
they will arrive.
We have to assume equally at a state of angelic perfection,
a state and winch in the state in which gender differences simply don't obtain.
Because angels as we know,
can either sex assume or both.
There were,
um,
there were a few other radical thinkers in the 17th century who embraced,
uh,
this,
this vision of a moment instick vision of the universe,
light like Milton's.
And almost invariably,
uh,
this Montez is and had a kind of leftist progressive and in some cases actually
a communist,
um,
energy to energy to it.
I've written the name of,
um,
uh,
one of Milton's contemporaries,
Gerard Winstanley,
um,
who was England's first,
maybe not England's first communist,
but England's first important communist writing 15 or so years before,
before paradise lost.
The bodies of all men and women are,
are four.
Winstanley as leader for Milton are equally infused with heavenly spirit and
heavenly soul.
And this for Winston Lee Nelson wouldn't permit himself to go quite this far.
Um,
this physiological equality seemed to guarantee their political equality.
And in adopting this doctrine of modernism that had been developed or worked out
by much more radical thinkers like that,
like,
like Gerard Winstanley,
Milton is really on some level consciously adopting a philosophy of body and
spirit that works to,
to undo.
Maybe it works to undermine that Patriarchal insistence on Adam superior
superiority over eve on some level.
Um,
some of the philosophy in book five,
I think is working on a subterranean,
uh,
at some subterranean stage to undermine or dismantle the Edenic paradise whole
hierarchy.
So Adam and eve before the fall,
or given the,
given the opportunity to reach their heavenly destinations on their own.
Now just think,
think how radical that is when you compare it to any mainstream notion of,
of the way Christianity works.
Adam and eve,
had they never fallen,
had they never sinned,
would never have needed to rely on a god or a Messiah to intervene and external
redeemer tip to move in and save them or even to reward them for their virtue.
There.
Virtuous behavior would have been itself a reward.
They're there.
We can think of them as having been in a position almost to save themselves.
And Melton is arriving at,
uh,
it's,
it's a wild and really daring alternative to the Orthodox Christian vision of
redemption and salvation.
Um,
and it's,
uh,
it's,
I think it's this orthodox notion of Christianity that Milton always felt so
uncomfortable with.
And were it not for the fall?
There would have been no need for the heavenly father to sacrifice the son in
order to save fallen humanity.
Human beings would have been able to just,
just waft up to the pearly gates,
a Wah Wah like helium balloons,
lighter,
even than air.
Um,
no need,
no need for an external redeemer.
In some ways Milton is,
is flirting with something like,
and I think the,
the,
the children's or the young adult book writer,
Philip Pullman Ex,
uh,
absolutely has put his finger on something important.
And Milton,
um,
he's a great reader and fan of Milton's,
is flirting with something that we would recognize as science fiction.
It's a secular image of salvation certainly,
but it's a prodo scientific image of,
of salvation and fallen.
Salvation is something like a scientific process.
It's the logical and inevitable result of a,
just a particular type of virtuous natural behavior.
And Milton arrives,
arrives at a theology that does something that a theology has never supposed to
do.
It's a,
it's a radical theology of bodily transformation that essentially does away with
God or does away with God as we know him.
Um,
who needs God.
Adam and eve,
we'll continue to eat.
They'll eat virtuously,
there'll be good people,
they'll become angels.
And eventually they will be up subsumed into that universal ball of,
of spiritual matter.
At that later point when God becomes all and all it,
that's that distant point in time where there were,
were,
there will simply be no ontological difference between man and woman,
between Angel and man or between us and God.
So Ralph fuels,
fuels philosophy of,
of,
of Moana.
ISM offers a truly radical vision of,
of an exaltation.
This possible.
Th th this pre-labs area notion of an exaltation of Adam and Eve up to heaven.
They,
they,
they could have exalted themselves and presumably we all could have exalted
ourselves simply by being good,
but by doing it ourself.
But this,
this,
this vision,
this daring vision of a radical self determination couldn't possibly be more
violently opposed to the version of exultation that RAF Raefiel explains to Adam
and Eve elsewhere in book five.
This scene,
I know you remember,
um,
upon Adam's prompting because it's so,
it's so upsetting and so unforgettable on Adam's prompting.
Raefiel goes onto describe the exaltation,
the anointing of the son of God.
It's an event that comes as close to anything as explaining the very first
mystery of the poem,
which is the or the central mystery of the poem.
That being the cause and the origin of Satan's fall.
Now the origin and you have,
um,
you can,
you can refer to your handy little chronology,
uh,
written by Allister Fowler of events in,
in paradise lost.
The,
the origin of Satan's fall is without question,
one of the most crucial problems that we have when we confront this,
this poem,
God's ways on some level,
God's ways can't be justified until the origin of man's fall can be explained or
understood and man's fall can't be understood or explained or justified until
Satan's fall is explained.
And so to account for Satan's fall,
Milton realize he,
he makes all this happen.
It's magnificent.
He's relying here on the text of the Second Psalm,
a chapter of the Bible that he had himself translated into English and 1653.
Now the second psalm imagines the Messiah speaking.
Uh,
this is the,
this is that first the Lord to me has said,
thou art the Son speaking the Lord to me,
had said,
thou art my Son,
I have begotten thee this day
and no one has ever known what to do with that passage from the second songs,
the idea that the Messiah could actually remember the day that God had big
gotten him,
had,
had for centuries,
Millennia,
provided biblical commentators with a paradox that really bordered on the
absurd.
What could God has meant when he said,
I have be gotten the this day and Milton worries and worries this problem of,
of this beginning.
And He'd,
and he does this throughout paradise lost and he does it in a number of ways.
He transforms this,
this mysterious declaration that he is lifted from the second song into the,
he's turned it into what is essentially the originary event of the entire poem.
And so as you can see from the,
from the chronology of the poem that Fowler gives us,
uh,
the Exaltation of the Son of God.
And,
and Fowler unfortunately calls him Christ.
Milton's son of God doesn't really function as a Christ.
He's not,
he,
he Milton would never in a million years,
certainly in paradise lost call this fellow Christ.
He doesn't call him Jesus either because the son of God is in Jesus,
yet he is preexistent but he's not a Christ.
Um,
I think in part because Milton doesn't want us to,
to confuse,
confuse or to construe this son of God with anything that we've learned from any
of our Sunday school classes or any exposure to traditional orthodox,
mainstream Christian,
Protestant or Catholic thinking.
Um,
this is the event.
You'll remember how important first events are in paradise lost.
This is the event that seems to have happened first.
W what,
what occurred,
what occurred in heaven before this moment.
The poem gives us no,
no definitive clue.
Although Satan knows there is something important that happened before this
moment and it makes it an important conjecture about it.
Um,
prior to this.
And we don't have time to look at this today.
Um,
but you,
you,
uh,
you may want to study for yourself.
Satan's own a theory of a first creation,
and that's the creation of the angels.
So God,
the father a assembles all of the angels.
This is page 316 in the Hughes.
Um,
book five line 600
and God delivers at line 600 a pronouncement.
That is by any standards absolutely shocking.
I'm Satan,
like the other angels was a son of God,
but unlike the other son of God,
this other sons of God,
Satan had been one of the first arc angels in heaven.
And the narrator suggests this is coming from the new radar that fits.
Satan may have been the first Archangel and heaven first,
both in God's favor and also in his general preeminence over the other angels
because God liked him most liked him best.
And also because he was simply better than all of the other angels.
And Milton continues his,
his meditation on the multiple meetings here of,
of first.
Now I'm going to read this passage to you and you tell me,
you tell me if you think I'm Satan.
Might have just to TNC a bit of a reason to be miffed at God's exaltation of
another one of his sons or what we have to assume is another one of his sons.
Uh,
this is God at Leiden 600 here.
All the angels,
progeny of light,
Thrones,
dominations,
Princeton's virtues powers here my decree,
which unreal Volk shall stand this day I have Bichotte whom I declare my only
son and on this holy hill him have anointed whom you now behold at my right hand
your head,
I him a point and by myself have sworn to him shall bow all knees in heaven and
shall confess him.
Lord under his great Vice Jarrett Reign,
abide United as one individual soul forever happy.
What's the tone of voice?
I'm going to interrupt myself for a moment.
How do we,
how are we to imagine God pronouncing that word happy after what he's just told
us under his great Vice Jarrett Reign,
abide United as one individual soul forever happy him who disobeys me.
Disobeys Breaks Union and that day cast out from God and blessed it.
Vision falls into utter darkness.
This,
of course,
it's a vision of an exaltation almost diet diametrically opposed to the
exaltation of the,
of the and fallen Adam and eve there wafting up the son,
the son of God.
The Messiah doesn't seem to have exalted himself along what has already been
established as the is a recognizable pattern of a kind of natural physiological
ascent.
And you can imagine,
you can imagine Miltona he could,
he could have pulled that off.
It's possible to imagine us cause he could,
he could pull off anything.
It's possible to imagine a scenario whereby the son had on some level eaten his
way into God's favor and,
and achieve the status of Messiah through an Adam and Eve,
like virtuous metabolism and floating up to the very top of God's throne before
any of the other angels.
That's how damn good he was.
But that's not the story that we get according to the narrative we have.
God,
the Father Sims seems quite simply to have decided to have decided arbitrarily
to a point,
one of the angels over all of the others.
Why has he done this?
God does mention something about the sun's merit.
Well,
he will mention something about the sun's merit later in another scene of
exaltation,
but it's one that's already been narrated.
And that's the scene that we've already read in book three,
um,
ads for this moment right now.
The motives for this declaration seem perfectly and explicable absolutely
inscrutable.
And it also seems clear that this inscrutability,
uh,
is this is the point of gods of the father's declaration.
And as a,
as William Thompson writes,
um,
convincingly and,
and brilliantly,
although mischievously in his wonderful book called Milton's God,
the father's declaration sounds like a challenge.
Like it's intended to be taken as a challenge by saying on this day,
I have B got the messiah.
God seems almost to be suggesting that.
I don't know that he's just created this guy out of,
uh,
out of whole cloth for this very occasion,
just,
just made him and raised the raise this nobody to the rank of favorite.
It's possible that God has just bequeathed all of his power to someone who
hasn't even been around someone who hasn't spent it,
turned it,
paying his dues.
Uh,
wha wha what could God have been thinking that the father,
the father knows this is a,
this is an extraordinary thing to be declaring.
And so he tries to soften the blow.
I guess this blow of this,
uh,
this show of favoritism by inviting the angels to the other angels to abide
under his Great Vice Jarrett rain,
United as one individual soul,
forever happy,
and by individual,
uh,
the,
the father means indivisible.
Here I,
I'm convinced that the word individual,
which only appears twice in paradise lost is one of the poems,
most important words.
Um,
but it has its original meaning.
Uh,
it's etymological meaning,
which simply means can't be.
It can't be divided.
Uh,
and this is on some level,
the father seems to be making a stab at Milton's own modernistic vision of
egalitarianism.
The angels will all be United as one individual soul,
but the father will only invoke this harmonious,
indivisible union when after he's placed the son of God at the head of the
other,
at the head of the other angels.
And we're left to wonder just how we're supposed to reconcile this image of any
of the indivisible egalitarianism with the competing image of an unyielding,
rigorously enforced angelic hierarchy.
And you can recognize in this scene that the opposition of irreconcilables that
we've already encountered,
they're the ones that had characterized the power relations in Milton's Eden.
Milton charges this scene in heaven with,
with its power,
I think by juxtaposing just those two forces that he was continued continually
attempting to unite in,
in book four,
he yokes together the principles of freedom and equality,
freedom and equality on the,
on the one hand and the opposing principle of,
of hierarchical order on,
on the other hand.
So think how the politics,
the politics and heaven here parallel the,
the political dynamic that we've already been exposed to,
uh,
that we've already seen operative on,
on earth.
Um,
in book four at that beautiful originary moment at the pool side,
eve had I think quite like Satan.
Eve had imagined herself great in favor and preeminence.
Uh,
she's,
she's shaken from this assumption of,
of power and of absolute self sufficiency.
When she suddenly told that there's another creature,
Adam,
who has been appointed her head,
and just as God does with Satan,
Adam,
Adam tries to soften the blow of this arbitrary declaration of hierarchical sub
supremacy.
Am Adam softens the blow by blow,
by claiming to be United indivisibly to eve.
So Adam declares to eve,
he sees as her hand she yields and he declares to her that he will have her by
his side,
hence forth and individual solace.
Deer and Milton is clearly doing something here in these two scenes with these,
with these noisy protestations of of indivisibility,
he invokes the beautiful notion of the interconnectedness of all of God's
creatures.
That's implicit in this monistic vision of,
of the first matter.
But,
but he only employs this beautiful image of a moment,
mystic unity when he's placing an absolute divide between the superior creature
and an inferior one between a greater and a lesser being and and on,
on some level.
And it's very troubling.
Mona,
Mona mystic indivisibility is always invoked at the most divisive moments in
the,
in the poem.
We can think of these as the crisis moments in paradise.
Lost and at these critical moments of the arbitrary subjection of one party or
the over the other,
whether it's Adam over eve or the son of God over Satan and the other angels,
you can the emergence of another meaning the modern meaning of that word,
individual dick.
The individual is a noun rather than individual as an adjective.
Dictionaries and historians of the English language claimed that the modern
meaning of the word individual,
a noun referring to a person who is self sufficient,
autonomous,
independent,
uh,
being,
um,
that this,
this now doesn't appear in,
in,
in England until later in the,
in the 17th century.
MMM.
But I think that it's precisely at these crisis moments in paradise lost that
Milton uses the original,
the traditional sense of individual and adjective meaning and divisible only to
begin pushing that word.
Um,
and,
and forcing it into something like its modern sense of individual,
the modern,
essentially liberal idea of a person,
um,
as a of a human being as an absolutely isolat self-determining fundamentally
unaffiliated person
here at the,
at the,
the scene of the Sun's exaltation.
Milton,
I don't know for a lot for a lot of readers,
this is really a repellent scene.
Um,
it's a,
it's a scene of a tyrannical and arbitrary ordering of a society.
And,
and Milton does this only to,
to display a little window,
I think onto a totally different kind of society.
You can see in this word individual,
a glimpse into the world of,
of what we can think of is modernity.
Paradise lost is,
is just on the cusp of,
of a liberal worldview.
And,
and the poem provides us a glimpse of the liberal world of equal individuals,
a world of rational self determination and self exaltation rather than the
arbitrary subjection of one class of creatures or over another class.
So it's,
it's one thing for Satan to witness this seemingly arbitrary exaltation of the
Sun.
This arouses in him,
as you can imagine,
uh,
feelings of injustice that of course famously lead him to coax a third of all of
the other angels in a rebellion against God.
That was bad enough,
but it's an entirely different matter I think when Satan learns.
Yeah.
I don't know if learns is the right verb.
When Satan hears in his discussion with Ab deal that God created everything,
including the angels themselves by means of the agency of the sun,
through the sun for Satan.
This is a,
this is a mind blowing revelation.
Um,
and it's,
and it's hard to miss as so surprising because we take this as just orthodoxy
that any went right thinking Christian might accept.
Um,
look at page three,
two.
This is line eight 35 of book five.
Um,
when Abdul Tell Satan,
well,
you know,
why are you so upset?
Satan?
Of course he would exalt the sonic was the son through whom we were all created.
And this notion just push us Satan,
I'm further than anything pushes them.
And this new revelation pushes him into making one of the greatest formulations,
um,
uh,
of the,
of the modern,
an outrageous one.
But it's central to the modern principle of individualization.
So let me give you a little background.
Abdul has traveled with Satan and the other disloyal angels,
the rebel angels to the northern quarter of heaven.
But Abdul like Milton himself during the English revolution and deal is in some
way Milton's self portrait deal was willing to distance himself from the mob
sensibility of the,
of the rebels.
He stands up to Satan with the pious rage.
Th the zeal that Milton always fancied himself capable of.
And so Abbeydale asks Satan,
and this is at the top of page three 22 how he can dare to question God's
justice in exalting the sun over the other angels.
It was the sun,
it was the sun by whom Abdul tells Satan it was the sun,
by whom as by his word,
the mighty father made all things,
even the and all of the spirits of heaven by him created in their bright
degrees.
Abdul Tell Satan that if it weren't for the son of God,
Satan would never have been created.
And it's Satan.
Satan is seemed,
certainly seems to be shocked here and it's his response to Abdul's deals claim
that is I think one of the most stunning,
one of the most outrageous moments in paradise.
Lost Line eight 52 st and his aghast that we were formed then say snow now and
the work of secondary hands by task transferred from father to the son.
Strange point and new doctrine which we would know when slurred.
Who saw when this creation was remembers now by making while the maker gave the
being we know no time when we were not as now.
No,
none before us.
Self big sell phrased by our own quickening power when fatal course had circled
his full orb,
the birth mature of this,
our native heaven ethereal sons.
Now nearly everyone agrees that the old Milton critics agree that this claim for
angelic self creation is in one way or the other crucial to our understanding of
the fall of the rebel angels and Satan's justification of the rebellion.
And this claim of self creation obviously prepares Satan for that pronouncement
that he will make later in hell but which comes at the beginning of the poem
that claim for the absolute priority of the mind.
The mind is its own place and can make a heaven of Hell,
a hell of heaven.
Uh,
now Abdul Abdul surely is right to insist that not only were the,
I mean how,
you know,
we have to give it to ab deal,
that he's,
he's,
he's on to something that,
that the angels were created and not only that they were created,
but in all likelihood by the agency,
through the agency of the sun.
But even though Ab deals,
right,
Satan's,
Satan's theory of angelic origin isn't easily dismissible.
Um,
it's not as easily dismissible as it is by cs Lewis and the,
and the little quotation at the bottom of the handout.
Um,
and so I,
I always tried to make a little plug for the validity of at least a little of a
part of Satan's claim.
And I want to do this because on some level,
I think what Satan's,
Satan's outrageous argument here is one of the greatest thing that anybody gets
to say in paradise lost because of her going to understand that the origin of
Satan's fall,
we have to understand something about the origin of Satan himself.
And so you have the chronology on that,
that the handout,
it's right to place the exaltation of the Sun as the first event officially
described in paradise lost.
But there's of course an event that happened before that which Milton's
narrative very carefully never describes.
And that's the creation of the angels.
And,
and,
and so we get Satan's theory of the creation of the angels and,
and Ab deal as we would expect,
takes great offense.
Uh,
but,
but it's important and ab deals ride and Satan's wrong,
but it's important to determine exactly what is wrong about Satan's uh,
uh,
what about say what it's wrong about Satan's theology here and how it would
counter Milton's.
Satan's obviously wrong to,
to ascribe the creation of the angels to something like a random occurrence of
fate.
Uh,
when,
when Satan says,
when fatal course had circled his full orb and in Milton's explained a number of
times in the poem that there's no such thing as a power called faint.
So that's easily dismissible.
But it's not absolutely clear to me that Satan has wrong to claim that the
angels are self raised by their own quickening power.
I think on some level this,
this has to be seen as true,
at least according to what we know of the processes of the dynamic processes.
In Milton's account of the Mona's Dick Creation,
God has impregnated matter with spirit.
And after this initial active impregnation,
he seems able to allow this spiritualize matter pretty much to organize itself
on its own,
into,
to all these beautiful and varied forms of creation.
And if we're not completely shocked to hear of Satan's claim for having raised
himself by his own quickening power,
um,
at least upon a rereading of paradise lost per that,
that might be because it looks an awful lot like the theory of creation that we
get in a,
in book seven and also like a moment in book three that we've already
encountered when the Angel Uriel,
the angel that Milton credits for having the best eyesight in heaven rather
remarkably.
And when Uriel gives us his eye witness account of the creation,
it sounds a little bit like Satan's
Satan's argument that the angels are so phrased
has something like I think something like a foundation even in book five itself.
And it begins to resemble the con that that condition of absolute self
determination that Rapheal had promised to Adam and eve if they remained
obedient.
If Adam and eve will only remain sinless,
there'll be able to raise themselves to that dead,
that ethereal state of,
of,
of angelic status.
And it's,
this is a world in which individuals rational self determining individuals
determine their own status rather than except one that has been arbitrarily
imposed upon them.
This is an egalitarian world that Milton is introducing us to.
And,
and I think that there in moments such as these,
we see Milton laboring to arrive at a theory of matter and a theory of creation
that can support something like a poetics,
poetics,
but also a philosophy of political philosophy of egalitarianism to claim that
matter can move itself to organize itself into stars and into angels,
which is what Uriel will will claim happens.
Um,
is essentially to lay the physical,
the Philosophical Foundation for a political philosophy that's not authoritarian
by any stretch.
It's not even hierarchical.
It's egalitarian.
This is a physics,
a theological physics that can bolster the claims of a politics.
It's a philosophy that can imagine human beings as being equally capable of
organizing themselves and creating their own sense of order without the
meddlesome intervention of an arbitrary God.
Now,
many of my,
many of my colleagues in the,
in the Milton community,
um,
dismissed the possibility that there could be anything even remotely like
something valid in Satan's wonderful rejoinder to ab deal.
And they nearly always overlook the,
the,
the creation account that we get from Uriel and book three,
which I think,
uh,
supports on some level part of Satan's claim.
And there eve,
they're also eager to,
to dismiss Eve's feelings of injustice at her inferior status.
They dismiss it as just another one of Milton's unquestioning acts of misogyny.
But I don't think it's unquestioning at all.
Um,
all three of these examples for me demonstrate Milton's willingness to question
nearly every form of religious and social and political orthodoxy.
Milton has continually putting the official doctrines of even his own poem on,
on trial.
He's continually pitting the narrator's own celebration of hierarchy,
his own Milton Zone and celebration of hierarchy,
um,
against a more subversive and a more questioning of philosophy.
Vic Galatarian ism and Milton's narrator and Milton is with him onto his stomach
to some extent come down,
comes down most firmly on the side of a divinely established hierarchy.
But the,
the,
this,
this exquisitely textured,
richly textured poem
can be distinguished.
And I,
in fact,
I think it has to be distinguished from the views of the narrator.
Oh,
on some incredibly important level that's not on the level of what the narrator
tells us.
The poem is itself insistently Egalitarian and I mean that in a special sense.
It's a gala Terrian in the sense that it's a poem rather than a dumb dogmatic
treatise or a work of political philosophy as a poem.
Paradise lost places,
all of it's divergent theories and all of its competing,
eating,
uh,
competing ideologies and visions of the way the world works.
Places them all side by side on something like a level playing field,
the playing field of the poetic line and the poem connects these competing ideas
with a,
with nothing more leading than that most liberal of all conjunctions or of this
port.
This,
this poem makes the reader the equal of the poet because either this is the case
or that is the case in Milton is always telling us to decide ourselves.
The poem lays down and I'll conclude here,
or range of ideological possibilities and it does that,
um,
from the,
from its opening line two,
it's too,
it's closing line and then it permits the reader,
or maybe I should say,
it forces the reader to choose among these possibilities.
Okay.
So books us,
we're on a roll.
This is our big week.
A book seven and eight.
Four for next time.